le 26 décembre la tempête le tarava j'ai
effectivement la france d'ouest en est
s'il va le kent retrace son parcours la
tempête arrive par le nord de la
bretagne
il est deux heures du matin des vents
d'une violence exceptionnelle
s'engouffre sur le pays les habitants du
calvados font partie des premières
victimes leur région ce matin là
ressemble à un champ de bataille
les vents soufflaient à plus de 170 km à
saint pierre sur dives la vie les
sinistrés à 80% des dizaines de tonnes
de béton de pierre et de bois se sont
envolés des billes écrasé une femme est
tuée ici par la chute de sa cheminée
au total 18 personnes vont trouver la
mort dans le nord ouest dans toutes les
casernes
les pompiers sont débordés à rouen la
cathédrale est touché en plein coeur un
clocheton a crevé la voûte et s'est
écrasée 28 mètres plus bas
pendant la pressent de retrouver des
images de 44 l'an de haut rang devant la
cathédrale sous l'effet de la pluie du
vent
plusieurs dizaines de cours d'eau
sortent de leur lit à fécamp cette rue
est en veille par une coulée de boue
vers 7 heures du matin la tempête arrive
sur l'île de france les vents n'ont pas
faibli en pénétrant à l'intérieur des
terres 216 km heure au sommet de la tour
eiffel baril est sens dessus dessous les
colonnes morris son pater et plusieurs
centaines d'arbres centenaires se sont
écroulés on a écouté les personnes âgées
qui sont là depuis
en temps n'ont jamais connu ça et j'en
tremble encore
à paris près de 60% des toits sont
endommagés les pompiers ici aussi sont
submergés les bois de boulogne et de
vincennes ne sont plus que des champs de
ruines
cent quarante mille arbres sont balayées
vers 9 heures la tempête se déplace vers
l'est à 20 strasbourg nancy et metz ont
touché de plein fouet une seule
préoccupation se mettre à l'abri le plus
rapidement possible comme ailleurs le
travail de plusieurs générations
d'agriculteurs s'est envolé dans la
région de troyes les 6000 mètres carrés
de cette serre sont balayés en quelques
minutes des centaines de pylônes sont
réduits à l'état de ferraille
ce jour là plus de deux millions de
personnes seront privées d'électricité
80% des routes secondaires sont coupées
au nord de la loire
ce 26 décembre la france se réveille
sous le choc ce jour-là 53 personnes
trouveront la mort et les esprits
resteront marqués à jamais